[Music]
[Applause]
bill auram covers the lakers for the
athletic he's been a busy guy um
if somebody didn't see the game last
night how would you describe how the
lakers played
well i think at the end of the game i
tweeted that it was a dreadful result
and you know it's it's it's really an
accumulation of a lot of things the
pacers aren't very good they've lost 10
in their last 11 games the lakers had a
15 point lead in the first quarter look
they got 30 points from lebron james and
you know i'd say russell westbrook
wasn't doing the things that we usually
think of as being
bad rust things turn he only had one
turnover he shot four of six from three
but he still ended up having a terrible
night from the field he was not
finishing around the rim and he ends the
night on the bench something we haven't
seen this year with frank vogel who's
kind of you know
really coaching for his job as we
reported earlier this week on kind of a
night to night basis you know throwing
the kitchen sink at the pacers which in
this case was not playing the the
highest the 44 million dollar guy yeah
i'm just i'm just trying to understand
if this is fixable bill
because it feels like okay get rid of
the coach that doesn't fix effort and a
lot of what i saw or what i see on
defensively is there's no effort
uh so how do you fix this can you fix
this this season
yeah i mean that's i think that's what
the front office is weighing you know
what do you sacrifice this season in the
name of you know pursuing a championship
when that might already be lost with
this team
and you know you do
see
coaching changes sort of shake up a team
psyche give them a kick start you know a
kick in the butt whatever um but we've
also seen the lakers play for david
fizdale this year they went 1-4 with him
when frank vogel had covet and that's
maybe an unfair uh way of judging david
fizdale as a potential replacement given
all the all that was going on with
replacement players but i do think the
lakers sort of got a glimpse of what
that might look like and if they weren't
you know um
you know if they weren't really excited
about that you know maybe that gives
them pause on making a change and you
know last the last uh previous two years
jason kidd was on the bench and that was
somebody the lakers held in really high
regard somebody who um if not for some
of the baggage might have been a
candidate for the head coaching job in
in 2019 um instead he kind of comes to
the lakers and rehabs his image he would
have been a likely he would have been a
really obvious replacement if there was
a mid-season firing while he was on the
bench it's less obvious now uh with
david fizdale um and and phil handy and
mike penberthy as the lead assistants so
it's really
what what do you want to sacrifice this
year in the pursuit of something uh
short term when
you know i don't like like like like you
dan you know this doesn't seem like
something that is just going to um
is going to change with a new voice
what can they do with the trade deadline
very limited right i mean they have you
know basically three tradable pieces
when you look at um you know caleb
horton tucker who makes 10 million
dollars kendrick nunn makes five million
dollars and then they have a first round
pick way out in 2027 when you know
hopefully i'm gonna be on a robo fishing
for bass somewhere uh by then but um
but you know and then and then yeah okay
maybe you've got some second round picks
we know they were interested in cam
reddish from the hawks before we went to
the knicks and they were throwing around
a couple of second rounders they have
the the minimum contracts i mean here's
one thing the lakers have an abundance
of
it's a bunch of it's it's minimum
contracts that are totally disposable
because they signed so many guys in the
off season who are not playing and are
not contributing so if they needed to
get you know
up to five million dollars or seven
million dollars on contracts and then
throw in second round picks as
sweeteners you could trade ken bazemore
deandre jordan wayne ellington because
those guys aren't contributing right now
in the near term but again
if we're talking about tht kendrick nunn
and then that first down the road
what are you getting back that is
actually going to make it um make it
worth it because taylor martin tucker
with only a year and a half left on his
contract has more value to the lakers
than anyone else they're the ones that
you know found him developed him have
some confidence in him um have the
relationship i don't know that anybody
else values him as highly as the lakers
do and especially as a 10 million a year
player so it's gonna be really hard to
find an impact player at the deadline
for the lakers
anybody interested in russell westbrook
um you know there's there's always a
chance
uh you know one thing i think we've
learned in the nba is that there's there
is no such thing as an untrainable
contract but i do
think that we are getting very close to
the stage where russ is an untradeable
player um the contract on top of the way
he plays the way he changes your system
the way everything becomes about russ
and and sort of the diminishing returns
we've seen with him as a player i think
makes him you know really really
difficult to move and you know that's
kind of why a lot of people were so cop
so off guard by the lakers uh making
that investment in the off season that
it was um
a really big swing but also a really big
risk and when you take that risk you
don't have other cards to play you have
you have expended your bank account it's
like going all in on on on your you know
on your 16 year old's lemonade stand and
realizing nobody's thirsty it just
doesn't it did it it hasn't paid off yet
and you know the lakers don't have you
know that next move well okay if that
doesn't work then how do you adjust and
they don't have that next card to play
so is anyone interested in russell
westbrook you know the lakers don't have
the sweeteners to come off of his
contract they don't have the you know
the 2022 first and the 2024 first that
you know a team might want they don't
have you know i mean honestly the lakers
best trade sweetener right now is
probably austin reeves who is their
undrafted rookie who is playing really
meaningful minutes and has become this
real bright spot you know if i'm if i'm
a team trying to trade with the lakers
you know i'm not just asking for you
know all the all the guys who aren't
playing who i described earlier i would
also want a guy who can come in and
contribute in austin reeves and i i
don't know the lakers are gonna be able
to do that
why would the lakers leak this if you're
not gonna make a change
like what what tell me the game that's
played here of getting this information
out here you don't have to tell me who
the source is obviously but
you know they they wanted this out there
it feels like that fairly unfair
i prefer to think of it as really good
reporting
[Laughter]
i'm sure it was i'm sure it is my bad uh
so due to the great reporting this
information got out there why yeah i
think that there's a couple ways of
looking at it obviously um you know
i would i would actually say that frank
vogel has probably
uh got gotten a boost from the fact that
this information has been out there not
just not to say that that is where you
know
i'm not i'm not suggesting you sleuth
that that is where the information is
coming from but it you know i do think
that you know
the organization has taken a little bit
of a hit from the fact that this has
been
that this has been uh reported in the
way it's been framed that
um
that
you know that they are looking to make a
change but i think the general reaction
is like like you said what difference is
that going to make and who's going to
come in and do a better job and so i i
think that um well the team didn't even
step up last night bill i mean well
that was what was so interesting because
we didn't report this until after the
jazz game and there was a lot of
pressure you know i think there was just
a sense of pressure like a really heavy
you know the air was really heavy in the
crypt
on monday night against the jazz before
the lakers won that game but then um you
know once it was reported and then there
was some follow-up reporting from other
outlets kind of on the way the front
office was sort of applying pressure on
frank vogel
you you i thought last night was gonna
be a really interesting measuring stick
game to see how the how the locker room
responded and
it looked good in the beginning i would
have argued that you know that looked
like a team that was
you know playing for their coach and
then it completely disintegrated down
the stretch uh lebron you know
lebron started missing shots down the
stretch wasn't getting enough support
russ wasn't out there
um it seemed really disengaged there
seemed to be a lot of chippiness at the
end of the game a lot of saltiness so
you know and it's the timing dan is
really fascinating because if you were
going to make a change
you would thought it'd be last night
because they're about to go on this
six-game road trip that is going to be
brutal i mean they've got orlando
tomorrow night but then after that it's
miami brooklyn philly charlotte atlanta
those are all teams they could lose to
so um
the timing's really tough for them well
it's only 8 30 local time they're
you know
i was told i was told last night that
frank vogel was getting on the plane
today so if as as long as nothing
changed between you know midnight last
night and you know whenever they're
taking off for orlando 10 a.m or so uh
frank vogel's gonna be coaching the team
in orlando but it's interesting i mean
he's on the hot seat you know as he as
he loses to indiana and now going to
orlando you know for frank vogel i've
got to think that's like the ghosts of
firing's past so um
sure he's hoping to make it through just
those those uh
those those bad memories is he on the
plane coming back bill
he will be on a plane
but i mean i i do think that like
i don't want to say that that he bought
time with the the utah win i mean the
utah game was really pivotal if there
had been a similar result against the
jazz to what happened two nights earlier
against denver i think i think the front
office would have felt like they had no
other choice but now
not that the utah win itself lowered the
temperature but the the fact that they
they snapped the street they got a win
against the top western conference team
although a team that lost to the rockets
last night has now lost six of seven um
i do think that it sort of
kind of popped the balloon in a sense
where the lakers are willing to kind of
ride this out a little bit but it
doesn't mean um it doesn't mean it can't
get worse
although i will say uh i always always
refer to the the great jim murray's
quote which was there's nothing so bad
it can't be made worse by firing the
coach
bill thank you we appreciate your time
and uh have fun on the road trip
thanks so much dan appreciate it that's
bill auram done a great job great
reporting for the athletic of course
had the uh had the story about frank
vogel coaching for his job he's getting
on the plane this morning